messieurs bonjour et merci d'être avec
nous monsieur qu'elle fut pire première
question vous revenez un d'équateur vous
vous êtes rendus en tant qu'observateur
de cette élection et dans quel climat
social va se dérouler justement cette
élection écoutez c'est la certitude déjà
tout le problème qu'on a eu en tant
qu'observateur atteint sonnant en
arrivant sur place les effectivement de
constater beaucoup de tension dans le
pays du fait de l'organisation des
élections par le conseil national
électoral qui étaient treize remise en
cause notamment de la part des choristes
et la gauche en général et tout
l'intérêt du coup qu'il y ait beaucoup
d'observateurs internationaux pour
garantir le respect de la démocratie et
du processus électoral du premier tour
et tout le problème qu'on a aujourd'hui
c'est qu'on a une incertitude totale sur
le devenir du second tour comment
va-t-il se passer quand va-t-il se
dérouler alors effectivement il a
contextes locaux vides mais il y as qui
est le gars le second qui en face dahra
aux puisqu'on sait que c'est lui qui est
arrivé aux le candidat de la gauche de
corée a levé correa est arrivé 1er mai
qui est le second sc yacou perez et
guillermo olaso on ne sait toujours pas
les résultats officiels n'ont toujours
pas été dévoilés il ya un recomptage qui
est prévue à un recomptage qui va durer
encore plusieurs plusieurs semaines donc
on voit que le actuellement le processus
électoral est comment dire est assez
pourri par par par plusieurs affaires
par plusieurs intérêts qui sont très
différents qui ont déjà été révélés
récemment au sein du conseil électoral
et ça ne l'a être prêt pour le moment
rien présager de bon pour la tenue du
second tour donc il ya encore une grosse
incertitude est julienne qu'elle fût qui
vous parlez d'incertitude un instant
concernant à ce second tour de
l'élection présidentielle quel bilan
faites-vous justement du premier tour
alors le bilan du premier tour a grondé
stablement il ya au moins une donnée sur
lequel on sur laquelle on est sûr c'est
que on va vous arriver premier alors
malgré le conseil national électoral a
donné ses estimations il a peiné ces
résultats officiels mais le les
choristes sont encore majoritaires dans
le pays ça c'est une certitude
ensuite l'autre bilan qu'on peut qu'on
peut tirer c'est qu'effectivement le
conseil national électoral qui est un
terrain acquis de la révolution
choristes puisque c'était une instance
qui a été mis en place par correa pour
garantir la tenue des élections dans le
pays
c'est quelque chose qui est issu de la
révolution citoyenne
eh bien on voit aujourd'hui qu'il y
avait énormément de failles vous avez eu
des failles le jour de l'élection vous
avez des failles pour compter les voix
les jours d'après et maintenant vous
avez même plusieurs candidats qui se
disputent la seconde place avec aussi
une certaine forme d'ingérence dans les
nations étrangères notamment lauréat qui
est intervenu et qui participe à
l'accord entre guillermo olaso yacou
perez pour l'organisation du second tour
et pour le recomptage des voix donc l'un
des bilans qu'on peut faire c'est que
malgré avec le conseil national est un
acquis assez intéressant de la révolte
citoyenne puisqu'il peut permettre de
2040 il alla le bon déroulement du
processus électoral en equateur on voit
qu'il ya encore beaucoup trop
d'incertitudes c'est c'est encore très
brouillon et ccc s'est passé il ya
beaucoup trop d'intérêts au sein du
conseil national électoral qui pollue un
peu la bonne organisation des élections
rendez vous compte l'élection a eu lieu
le 7 février et encore aujourd'hui on
n'a pas les résultats officiels on n'a
que des estimations et on est parti pour
un recomptage de 50% des voix dans seize
ou dix sept provinces donc il ya encore
il ya encore des choses à arranger à
aller encore des choses à définir et à
perfectionner je dirais andré arous
candidat socialiste héritier de la
politique de rafael correa est arrivé en
tête du premier tour de cette élection
présidentielle est ce que c'est le
candidat d'un retour à une politique
plus sociale
il ya sûrement sur l'essence et de sa
campagne et c'est pour ça que l'école et
les équatoriens votaient pour lui c'est
tourné autour de la relance économique
de la lutte efficace contre le courant
navires us à l'opposition de ce café
lenin moreno qui est une gestion
catastrophique notamment sur la question
des vaccins d'aucune relance économique
la question du plein emploi
une forme de souveraineté économique de
nouveaux accords commerciaux et une
relance économique pour le pays et pour
les équatoriens
c'est essentiellement sur ça qu'il a
basé sa campagne bien évidemment
retourne sur la démocratie la lutte
contre la corruption et la lutte contre
le lot offert qui s'abat actuellement en
équateur mais le coeur même et la
question de la relance économique et qui
effectivement et on va dire aussi un
gars qui est un des principes
ou l'une des bases sur lesquelles aussi
s'est forgé le cauris mais lorsque
correa est arrivé au pouvoir et bien
évidemment corée a affiché son soutien à
andré house il reste encore le
personnage politique le plus populaire
dans le pays
bâle est le fait que la low faire lui
empêche actuellement de pouvoir se
présenter et de pouvoir faire de la
politique sur le territoire équatorien
cependant andrews bénéficie aussi de
cette eau plate et bénéficie encore de
la vague choristes et oui aujourd'hui
l'essentiel de son programme
une grande partie des 10 et 4 rien qui
veulent tourner la page de ligne morano
qui veulent aussi d'une certaine manière
tourner la page de ce que représente
guillermo olaso est aussi un peu les
yaaku perez malgré la surprise qu'il a
pu faire mais qui représente aussi un
peu les écoutera veulent tourner la page
de ce néolibéralisme tourner la page de
d'un manque de souveraineté économique
de l'équateur d'une mauvaise gestion
économique de la mauvaise gestion du coc
vide et c'est l'une des raisons pour
lesquelles ils ont porté à house premier
souffre cependant moi j'espère que le
résultat avons être très vite déclaré
pour que andrea raul est le seul
personnage qui arrive second coup soit
l'assaut perez puisse faire campagne
sereinement et qu'on puisse avoir un
second tour qui se déroule dans des
conditions qui d'un point de vue
démocratique sont saine sereine et et
sans problème et les observateurs
nationaux le relèverons à ce moment là
julian qu'elle fut qu'à vous parliez
d'incertitude 1 qui entourait cette
cette élection des incertitudes plutôt
électorale on sait que le pays a été
assez touché 1 par là la pandémie de
kovy de 19
est ce que la crise sanitaire justement
peut avoir un impact sur l'organisation
de ces élections
eh bien je n'espère pas puisque déjà le
premier tour a pu se dérouler aussi dans
un contexte de coûts vide avec un
respect là je peux en témoigner
un respect des normes sanitaires qui
était qui est et qui était très strict
qui était très bien organisé cependant
il ya eu d'autres problèmes notamment le
fait que beaucoup de gens se sont
amassés sur le sur les bureaux de vote
et n'ont pas pu voter
assez rapidement puisque avait un
protocole bon pour faire rapidement il
ya un protocole pour voter en deux trois
minutes
et malheureusement les gens mis beaucoup
plus de temps à voter ça a un peu traîné
les cas on se sont se sont enchaînés et
malheureusement c'est ce qui a fait
oublier beaucoup de gens qui soit passé
mais on relève pour le moment aucun
problème vis-à-vis du coc vide dans les
bureaux de vote et le jour de l'élection
moi j'espère que pour le second tour ça
se passe de la même manière pour cela il
aussi est il faut une garantie
actuellement de l'état du conseil
national et de l'actuel gouvernement au
pouvoir pour aussi restreinte cette
épidémie jusqu'au jusqu'au jour de
jusqu'au jour de l'élection
et ensuite il faut permettre les bonnes
modalités pour notamment le vote
électronique et le vote des étrangers ce
qui justement est un élément et qui est
en train d'être remis en cause par une
partie de la droite et du conseil
national électoral et que andrea house a
très récemment c'était hier aujourd'hui
dans un tweet à a dénoncé et donc ça il
faut absolument le relever car cela
empêcherait justement la bonne
organisation d'un second tour on peut
organiser un second tour en équateur le
les toits de neige et le l'état
équatorien de se donner car ans et
conseiller national de se donner car ans
pour l'organisation d'un second tour
sans merci beaucoup de jeunes qu'elle
fut pire d'avoir été avec nous cet après
midi sur arte france rappelle que vous
êtes secrétaire national du parti de
gauche est responsable international des
jeunes insoumis merci beaucoup